we're given a two vehicle government
Army escort to head towards the besieged
city of Taz
it's been split in two for most of the
past eight years of war with most key
roads into and out blocked off by
fighting
well that's meant to unique
unique torture for the Tas civilians
with the houthi militia held to one half
of the City by government troops who
control the other
the city has been blasted to bits in
places with booby trap bombs buried in
gardens by the retreating Fighters and
mines hidden in kitchen ovens to blow up
any returning residents they've been
planted down Alleyways and left in the
piles of rubble and rubbish
The Siege has brought parts of Taz to
the brink of starvation yet families are
still living here
Muhammad chose us round the bombed out
shopping center which is now his home
his family is living in the basement
a lot of damage to every floor that
we've visited so far a lot of hits on
just this building alone
over there is one of the houthi bases
Muhammad tells us it's by the old
presidential Palace it's from there
snipers pick off civilians or fire
Rockets
three of Muhammad's children were born
in this Siege they all show signs of
malnutrition and spend most of their
lives inside
of course I worry about the Muhammad
says this isn't a safe place I don't let
them go outside on their own in case
there are Rockets or anything
neither children nor pensioners are safe
Cabo was shot in the back by a sniper
her home is right on the front line and
she refuses to be pushed out
I refuse to leave my house she tells us
I refuse to the houthis would shout at
me crazy woman leave your house but I
will never ever leave
the war has never let up in Taz and
whilst there's increasing optimism about
a negotiated settlement for the country
those hopes seem to have halted at the
gates of this city
I don't know how close they all are
living to the front line at the end of
that road is where the fighting is no
man's land and dozens of families are
living in this area they've had to put
up sheets
to try and obscure the view of the
sniper who has positioned himself just
beyond there it means constant exchanges
between the warring groups
we're defending our land and our
families one tells us
we want peace another says but they
don't want it they're killing innocent
people and children and that's why we
carry weapons
this intransigence has led to one of the
world's worst humanitarian disasters
with starvation poverty and disease in
the hospital Wards homes and streets of
Yemen
three-month-old ayad is holding on to
Life by a thread the youngest of six
who've all had the same battle to
survive in a country where her mother
has to choose between food or medicine
when she can pay for neither
my daughter was very weak and we needed
to take her to the hospital she explains
well we didn't have the money so we had
to wait to try to get someone by then
she was unconscious
those like Fatima want Justice too the
mother of nine knows more than most
about loss
they were kids not Fighters she's
talking about her children four of them
were blown up in one day three were
killed outright the fourth only a
toddler lost a leg
photos of their mutilated bodies are all
she's left of her babies
and she's praying for revenge for their
violent deaths
she's compiled a file with their details
and wants to track down those who fired
the mortar shell that killed them as
they were playing outside their home
nothing can ever replace my children she
says
they'll never come back look at these
pictures she keeps saying to us they're
just children
she's pregnant again but would have
aborted if doctors had agreed
she doesn't want to bring another child
into this war-torn place
she can't feed those she still has her
two-year-old Malik has sweet tea with
yesterday's bread it's her first and
only meal of the day Alex Crawford Sky
News and Taz City Yemen
again